[Musique]
je veux pas vendre la mèche mais c'est
majordome c'est toujours mieux qu on
l'espère au mode routier le monde
que vous vous faire de l'autre côté de
l'océan c'est mourir un tonneau ce oui
votre mari est mort or deux petites mort
de fatigue il est en train de dormir
monsieur vous devait regagner votre
siège autrement je devrais appeler la
plus sale du shérif on est déjà mariées
depuis 15 ans mais on a vraiment
vraiment été extrêmement occupés mais
toile et dans la foi ça et tu va pas de
main morte cette foire charge nous
invite à passer le week end en sa
compagnie sur son yacht
ça ne te dérange pas de s'incruster avec
les autorités vous êtes actrice par la
crise va là haut up
je m'appelle knicks pitt et voici ma
femme alison à cette fin d'année audrey
je m'appelle entre audrey a déjà fait
des folies de ton corps sur un bateau
soit rallongé bateau
vous pensez qu'il faut l'enlever non ils
mesurent dans les 30 centimes devriez
écouter mon mari immédiatement vous
savez je ne leur remettait pas je me
présente inspecteurs laurent delacroix
je vais vous demander de me suivre pour
un interrogatoire pourquoi 100 rounds
fumer aussi réussi comment il fait ça
vous avez remarqué quelque chose qui
sorte est d'ordinaire mais où des
innocents
on est victime d'une machination bouffer
les choses à deux à l'heure s'il te
plaît on peut essayer de résoudre ça
ensemble
cette bourgade avant la bibliothèque
qu'est-ce qui se passe ils se font tuer
tous les cadavres à la bibliothèque
et toi vous fait la une des journaux ils
disent que vous avez tué quelqu'un tu
crois que c'est possible tout comme tu
t'y des tirs de semonce je te signale
thierry si on fait ça il faudra qu'on
ait l'air d'avoir confiance en moi
[Musique]
oh
ferrari testarossa thomas de son nom
c'est moi je roule
est ce que tu te rends compte à quel
point je t'aime tu trouves joue dix
minutes
[Musique]
we want to know
photo minutes
[Musique]
rudolph noureev
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plus que tout finisse
oui
audi
[Musique]
lescure bougies
y
christophe sur youtube
audi du reste c'est moi
[Musique]
zenit sauveteurs cette histoire nous est
tombé sur la tête
ma présence forme se vêtir
[Musique]
de chaudes aux alpes best
[Applaudissements]
ça risque de vous le donner à l'examen
c'est de faire ce à moins dé foi a + b
égal à cary on se moque frère je vais
ahmed a mais pourquoi tu vas là-bas
il ya un mois et étaient tout le temps à
jouer à la playstation avec karima
d'enlever tous les posters de ta chambre
tu serais d'accord qu'on discute du
corps une fois par semaine tous les deux
je peux pas lire le coran et enfin tu
préfères le lien avec un imam qui est un
menteur j'ai pas un moteur sinon c'est
un menteur à m mais le mieux c'est que
je te conduisent tout de suite à la
police pour pas qu'ils puissent dire que
c'est la voie qui est quitte à cacher
mais pour fermer mon temps non c'est
trop jeune a peut-être un mot 2
[Musique]
sur la deuxième tribune revient c'est
encore plus dur que la première
j'aimerais tellement que tout redevienne
comme tu es
s'ils veulent tenir
[Musique]
et
normal que ça prenne du temps pour
comprendre ce que tu as fait quand même
essayé de tuer quelqu'un et
contrairement à ce que disait ton cousin
la mort c'est autre chose qu'une piqûre
de moustique à m
[Musique]
matthias langhoff champion du monde
d'homophobie allez vas-y lâchement à
occuper des toits il a donc été décidé
de conditionner la participation de
matthias langhoff aux prochains
championnats du monde à une mission au
sein d'une association sportive
homosexuel avant de les conduire en
cross ou kaki
c'est quoi la meilleure façon de faire
un pressing de nettoyage à sec pourquoi
vous mettez votre vitalaire premier
temps si vous en avez rien à [ __ ] de
rien en fait
alors si vous supportez plus on n'est
pas obligé d'y aller d'accord les gay
games est pas qu une énorme fête c'est
aussi le moment où on peut montrer au
monde qu'on est solidaire et qu'on
existe une belle bande de mecs qui
traverse la moitié de l'europe en bus
c'est sûr il va se passer des trucs j'ai
une règle dans l'équipe
pas de l'oeuvre est entre crevettes
construit en maquillant quoi la chance
des [ __ ]
emma
non vous avez trouvé ça commence pour la
crevette le meilleur c'est là que fut
avec des paillettes c'est encore mieux
excusez moi c'est ici l'association
homosexuelle pour l'intégration la
tolérance et le respect dans le water
polo ensemble à une bande de [ __ ] je ne
sais pas maintenant vous ne reconnaissez
pas le matthias langhoff champion du
monde d'homophobie allez vas-y lâche
moins cupide et ouaret la caméra se fait
à temps qu'était décidé de conditionner
la participation de mathias le goff aux
prochains championnats du monde à une
mission d'intérêt général au sein d'une
association sportive homosexuels quoi
il aura la responsabilité d'entraîner
pendant trois mois dans les verres 200 m
en retrait au pédalage ça vous calme et
great wall à être [ __ ] avant de les
conduire en croatie
ok c'est quoi les gay games et comme géo
en moins chiant avec et des beaux mecs
[Musique]
ah les entraînements surprise olé c'est
quoi la meilleure façon de faire un
pressing fred de nettoyage à sec en
lesbienne cayenne et puis comme je
comprends plus rien on a le droit de
dire des trucs comme ça nous oui mais
toi non les habits qui j'en ai plein ce
sont des gens brillants extrêmement
rapide pourquoi vous mettez vos buts
allaient vite promettant s'ils sont
nickels vous en avez rien à [ __ ] de
rien en fait
alors si vous supportez plus on n'est
pas obligé d'y aller d'accord aussi tu
voulais vous abandonnez même ta propre
fille bien trouvera plus de voir les gay
games c'est pas une énorme fête c'est
aussi le moment où on peut montrer au
monde qu'on est solidaire et qu'on
existe moi j'ai pas le temps pour ce
cirque il ya sanction mathias une belle
bande de mecs qui traverse la moitié de
l'europe en bus c'est sûr il va se
passer des trucs
il ya une règle dans l'équipe pas de
vrais 30 rue crevettes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puis
le cas
[Applaudissements]
quand je pense qu'il y en a qui ont pas
la chance d'être père est il non vous
avez trouvé ça commence pour la crevette
le meilleur c'est l'accueil fut avec des
paillettes s'entend bien
en direct live c'est kate bradley pour
chanel 12 tu es la meilleure dans les
faits divers les incendies les
carambolages les émeutes du black friday
au centre commercial les responsables
sont furieux de te voir prendre autant
de risques j'appelle ça faire son boulot
de reporter ait ça suffit tu m'entends
rassurons appel d'une femme dans le sud
du bronx est dit avoir trouvé un sac
plein de billets de banque
elle est convaincue qu'il a été déposée
par un bon ça m'as tu fais un break sur
les événements show une femme trouve un
sac plein d'argent c'est même pas de
l'info croit pas à l'hypothèse du bon
samaritain j'ai pour principe d'être
toujours objective mais non une personne
nous observe et nous y emmener
et je dois dire que j'ai vraiment du mal
à croire qu'une personne puisse faire
une bonne action sans rien attendre en
retour
ce ne sont pas des faux j'ai trouvé le
sac ce matin devant notre part il a
laissé le souk juste là bien que la
semaine dernière
huit personnes ont trouvé 100 mille
dollars selon leurs familles en fait on
est là pour le bon sens une femme a créé
un club anonyme de bon samaritain est un
gars qui passe à la caisse d'une
boutique à régler anonymement les achats
des deep liant suivant marre quand j'ai
commencé à courir cette histoire j'étais
sûr que notre saint marc est un motif
qu'ils étaient inavoués maintenant il ya
des personnes qui font le bien autour
d'elle
[Musique]
l'intérêt pour ce généreux donateur ne
cesse de croître les habitants ne
parlent plus que de sa générosité et de
où et quand le prochain sacs remplis
d'argent pour réapparaître
certaines personnes disent que new york
est une ville difficile mais grâce au
ven sam
je ne vois plus que des marques de
sympathie entre un premier
bon samaritain nous inspire tous de
l'espoir les gens en ont besoin à notre
époque
c'est contagieux un peu comme les
miracles
mais
la question qui nous préoccupe donc tous
à présent qui est cet homme au coeur
d'or
lalonde